our next guest group with a unique
perspective on what it means to be an
American and he's written a book about
it his name is Rafael Augustine he moved
here from Ecuador to Southern California
when he was seven what he did not know
is that his family was carrying a secret
and it wasn't until he was in high
school that Augustine learned the truth
that he and his parents were
undocumented eventually he was able to
get U.S citizenship and went on to write
for the hit show Jane the Virgin and in
his Memoir illegally yours you didn't
really sign emails that way did you
Augustine documents his American journey
and Raphael joins us now good morning
thank you for being here thank you for
having me it would be your sense of
humor and completely hilarious to sign
emails that way I don't think I didn't
the book the book opens with um with I
think an anecdote that illustrates the
absurdity I think of the sort of lines
in the sand and rules about who can
cross and who can't but I actually want
to start with uh the moment you found
out your family's secret you were trying
to get a driver's license was pick it up
so I mean essentially the big Seekers I
grew up undocumented and I didn't know
it like my mom tried to shelter me from
this harsh reality so I grew up watching
friends and and you know watching Saved
by the Bell like everyone else and I
discover I'm undocumented and I don't
know how to react to it because there's
no episode of Saved by the Bell where
Zach gets deported that doesn't resolve
that one yeah so my All-American life
Came Crashing Down on Me as I discovered
the truth of our legality my mom
sheltered me from that and I thank her
for it because it allowed me to grow up
a oblivious All-American kid
go ahead well as I say why did you then
eventually decide to get to the point
where you know what I'm gonna put I'm
going to write it down
well I honestly I wanted to tell my
parents journey to this country I mean
we don't get to hear these stories in
our media and our film and our TV and
our books uh because your parents are
doctors both of them my dad is a
pediatric surgeon who came to this
country to work on a car wash my
mother's an anesthesiologist who came to
work at a Kmart and they struggled
really hard I mean they thought they
were going to come here to become
doctors again right it was their
American Dream but then they had the
harsh reality that the American dream
was not going to be for them but for
their children children and it's a harsh
reality that a lot of immigrants in the
United States have to come to face with
I know but I think of you as this little
boy Raphael you're watching uh Disney
cartoons DC Comics you wore your Batman
costume all around the time everywhere
at nine years old there's a little girl
Aaron is your first girlfriend Tony
there's that funny part in the book
where she leans in you think is she
trying to smell my shirt no she's trying
to give you a kiss
it was funny the way you wrote it but I
mean but also at that at that age I'm
like what does it mean to be someone's
boyfriend I mean I have to have extra
chores I didn't know I was a little
scary but you're watching Saved by the
Bell and you think I want to be Zach yes
and then later on you see Ricky Martin
and you go aha I want to be that guy
talk about the difference between the
two for you so as a first generation
American I didn't have a how-to guy
right I know how to be American so I
would watch and was like okay Saved by
the Bell I want I want to stop living in
this ghetto Hispanic Barrio and I want
West Covina High School where I grew up
to be like Bayside hide yeah Bayside
High so then everything Zach did and
every episode I tried it on for size I
mean he's gonna run for class prison I'm
gonna run for class present he's gonna
join a band I'm gonna join a band yeah
but then the late 90s come around in the
Latin explosion hit Ricky Martin takes
the stage of the Grammys and it truly
changed my life because he redefined
sexuality and what it was to be a Latin
man yeah unfortunately that sexiness
didn't trickle down to me like I kept
walking into like parties with my tight
shirts like no one cares I think a lot
of people watching disagree with you
right now not particularly loose shirt
you're wearing at the moment but you
apply you apply for this test and then
the questions that they that you're
asked there I knew all the questions
except for one for the citizenship yes
yes so I go take the citizenship finally
um and they ask you all the questions
like the 13 colonies the branches of
government and I'm like answering them
as quickly as I can and then it turns
out that the guy asking me the questions
the federal worker starts trying to
stomp me he starts asking me harder
questions and harder questions he brings
out another set of questions and I'm
like What's Happening less than 30
seconds what was the question
he said who was George Washington's
right hand man and that really did stop
me I see the painting I was like who's
George Washington I finally say I'm
sorry I don't know and he said oh my God
I don't know either but if you knew that
that would have been me yeah
that's great Raphael you say these
stories are not being told but you are
now in a position actually to tell these
stories and you've told it very well
thank you very much for being here the
book is illegally yours it is out right
now wherever you buy your books yeah